"The Matrix Resurrections" is a movie about
making "The Matrix Resurrections."
We cannot emphasize this enough.
"Am I crazy?"
"We don't use that word in here."
The end of “Resurrections” begins with
a much-anticipated sit down between Neo
and The Analyst. Their venue for this meetup is
the delightfully-named Simulatte coffee shop,
where Thomas Anderson has received much of his
stimulation over the years — and inspiration,
via a beautiful woman named “Tiffany” who bears
a striking resemblance to our old friend Trinity.
This "Tiffany" has a lot invested
in the world she sees every day.
She has a husband, a job, three children,
but also a persistent feeling there must
be more – as well as a relentless
affection for Ducati motorcycles.
At the coffee shop, Neo and the Analyst finally
lay all their cards on the table and decide to
let her break the stalemate. If Tiffany decides to
stay Tiffany, Neo will return to the Matrix once
and for all and become Thomas Anderson again; if
she decides to become Trinity, all bets are off.
The Architect, who says he likes tests,
accepts, saying, "We’ll let Tiff decide.”
Breaking down the stakes, the grown-up Sati
sums up Neo's dilemma with a single line:
“The most important choice in
Neo’s life isn’t his to make.”
After watching Moss’s character essentially
being lobotomized for most of the film,
what comes next is particularly satisfying.
As her husband and kids make one
last sales pitch, it appears that
Tiffany might return home with them;
just as Neo is being dragged away,
however, she delivers four words that
trigger the film’s ending — and perhaps, more
“Matrix” movies to come: “My name is Trinity.”
One of the more welcomed upgrades in “The Matrix
Resurrections” is the new Agent Smith. Although
Hugo Weaving was nothing short of iconic
in his work originating the character,
Jonathan Groff does a fine job as his new face.
At the end of “Revolutions,” it looked as
if both Neo and Smith had been destroyed.
With “Resurrections,” we once again see that
Smith and Neo’s fates are tied to each other.
As his “boss” becomes his “enemy,” Groff’s Smith
takes over in the key Matrix role of
engaging Neo in multiple high-powered,
memorable smackdowns. By the end of the film,
it looks as if Smith might have been eradicated.
But when Neo and Trinity need saving, Smith once
again returns from the dead, this time to fight on
their side. He substantially aids their efforts
in the Simulatte coffee shop. Then, vanishing
once again, he points out to our heroes, “Anyone
could be you. Whereas, I’ve always been anyone.”
What follows is all the butt-kicking, bullet
dodging, aerial acrobatic choreography
you would expect from a “Matrix” film,
this time with Neo and Trinity backed up
by a new crew led by Bugs. As the group
make their way out of the Simulatte,
the Analyst turns the Matrix against
these viruses threatening his creation.
In essence, every human in the area turns into a
quasi-zombie, attempting to take down the heroes.
When Trinity shows up on a Ducati and
has Neo hop on board, this sequence
gets particularly striking. As in, hundreds
of bodies striking the streets down below,
diving out skyscraper windows and
essentially turning themselves
into bombs attempting to hit Trinity and
Neo as they speed through the streets.
After many close calls, explosions and imperiled
colleagues, Trinity and Neo make it to their
destination. But what comes next? If people are
truly to be freed, the Analyst himself must be
confronted. But with Neo and Trinity united again,
and their minds freed, anything is possible.
With that bit of business concluded and
agents closing in, Neo and Trinity take
to the roof of a skyscraper, where
they take a great leap of faith.
Throughout “The Matrix Resurrections,” Neo
keeps seeing the same recurring image of birds
in flight, flying in some sort of time loop.
We are also told that Thomas Anderson tried to
step off the roof of a building at a corporate
party but was pulled back at the last moment,
an event witnessed by Bugs. Finally, it
becomes a sort of running joke throughout
“Resurrections” that people ask Neo whether he
can still fly – and he can’t make it happen.
All this builds to Neo and Trinity,
literally taking a leap of faith.
Stepping off the top of the building, holding
hands, at first they begin to fall — and you’d
be forgiven if you just assume Neo’s old skills
will kick in and he’ll save the day. Instead,
it’s Trinity who discovers an ability to fly.
Reminiscent of Neo soaring away at the end of
the original “Matrix,” this time it’s Trinity who
takes to the sky, with Neo along for the ride.
When the duo confront the Analyst together, this
time in his office, the power dynamic has shifted
considerably. Now, instead of dictating the
terms to Neo, surrounded by dozens of his agents,
he is on his heels and alone. But that doesn’t
stop the Analyst from bragging about his plans,
waxing philosophic about the
intrinsic shortcomings of mankind,
and telling the duo time and again
that their efforts are useless.
As if to drive home the point that he’s
the one fighting the losing battle,
Trinity kills the Analyst — again and again,
each time with him snapping back until he
finally seems to admit defeat. At this point,
the Analyst seems to shift from saying they’ll
never gain control to essentially saying
they’ll hate the burden of having control.
What are they going to do, he asks, rebuild
everything with rainbows in the skies?
As he puts it, “The sheeple
aren’t going anywhere."
At this point,the newly-reunited Trinity
and Neo resolve to do exactly that,
joking that the rainbow idea
actually sounds pretty nice.
If you stick around through the credits,
you’ll notice that when the title “The Matrix
Resurrections” is flashed on the screen,
it becomes “The Matrix Resurrects.” Could
this be the title of the next potential film?
Like the end of the original film,
the final moments are soundtracked
by the uplifting rebellion rock
of “Wake Up.” Only this time,
rather than the ferocious Rage
Against the Machine original,
the cover version you hear is by a band called
Brass Against, with help from Sophia Urista.
Unfortunately, the post-credits scene is a
real disappointment. When the titles lift and
the screen lights up again, we are transported
back to Thomas Anderson’s old place of work,
where his team are still debating new
marketing ideas and ways to make money
off the “Matrix” franchise. As in the
earlier scenes, it’s all very meta.
Someone says, “Face reality: movies are
dead, games are dead. Narrative is dead.”
Their solution? Create programming for felines:
a series of videos called the Cat-trix.
And, yeah, that's real. "The Matrix
Resurrections" is in theaters now.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.